who has experience escaping from a cult
well at hamz007 many people have escaped
from cults and i'm happy to say that i'm
one of them hi i'm dr yanya lalich i was
once an occult now i'm a sociologist who
studies and writes about cults today i'm
here to answer your questions on twitter
this is cult support
[Music]
at erie the fairy asked how did charles
manson even get a cult like ew
well at arie the fairy here he is
charles manson and he was a very
successful cult leader because at the
time which was the hippie days of the
60s and 70s you know people were
exploring they were doing new things
they were living in the streets charles
could come along and he had a very
spangly charismatic appeal he would look
in your eyes and he would draw you in
and also what's important about what
manson did was that he used drugs he
would often you know give one of the
girls lsd and she would believe that she
had some kind of you know enlightened
spiritual experience and that way she
felt even more bonded to charles but
that is unusual most cults do not use
drugs they don't need to use drugs
they're using basic social psychology at
my opinions man asks what's a movie
about cults that in your opinion is a
must watch working on something
regarding cults and movies and i'm
trying to grab every last hidden gem at
my opinions man i would say in my
opinion the best movie about cults is
the master with joaquin phoenix it's one
of the best depictions of the
relationship between the charismatic
leader and the true believer it's a very
tightly knit relationship that has an
imbalance of power because the one with
charisma has power over you and that's
the rub
so that person can pretty much get you
to do anything so that you get to the
point where you think you can't even
live without that person and of course
it's doubly interesting because joaquin
phoenix himself grew up in a cult and
well-read wife asks be honest with me
before i get sucked in is lularoe a cult
are we just buying our cute cult
uniforms lularoe is quite a questionable
retail organization at this point and i
don't think you want to wear that
uniform at beanieblover asks why do cult
leaders always have to be weirdo freaks
that abuse their members when will we
see a cult leader who's really just a
chill guy cult leaders are not going to
be chill cult leaders are power hungry
individuals who are typically
narcissists who believe that the world
revolves around them they aren't
necessarily weirdo freaks some of them
may look like a classy businessman
remember the leader of heaven's gate
this is what he looked like when we saw
him on those video clips the night
before they all committed suicide but
this is not what marshall applewhite
looked like when he was recruiting
followers he kind of had that
professorial look or like your your nice
uncle the cult leader might become a
little demented might start using too
many drugs might start looking really
weird but they certainly don't start out
that way because who would follow a
weirdo at marina c asks i'm intrigued by
the heavens gate cult why the nike shoes
there was a complete lack of
individuality in the heavens gate cult
people had to dress in a way that they
were completely androgynous so they wore
what they considered was their uniform
everyone had the same patch on their
sleeve they all went out and bought
these nike shoes it was just part of
their outfit there was certainly no
special meaning to it but again it was a
way to
make them all be exactly the same so
that they all went along with the idea
that they would drink that poisonous
potion
put the bag over their head
and
go to their homeland they didn't believe
they were committing suicide they
thought they were choosing life
in fact let me read you from this is one
of their books called ruffles
snacks for thinkers this book was given
to me by dick jocelyn who was one of the
longtime members of the group it's dated
july 7th 1979
and they all contributed little sayings
to this book
life is not a time to prepare for death
death is a time to prepare for life life
is a time for learning to live
like the one who came to show us how
they believed that they were going to be
picked up by a spaceship
and taken to what they called the level
above human where they were going to
live forever in a paradise and the rest
of the the world and the earth was just
going to be shattered and destroyed at
toneboy asks neighbors on our street are
trying to barricade themselves in are
the branch davidians still a thing
if so do they have a twitter account or
do i go straight to the fbi we have kind
of a policy in our country of not paying
too much attention to what the neighbors
do and one of the fallouts of that is
sometimes we do have a cult next door
there are still people who believe in
david koresh and who actually think he's
coming back i don't think those are your
neighbors maybe your neighbors are just
trying to get away from the world maybe
they don't like you three forms our
powerhouse asks who are the moonies the
moonies are
the moon organization that was founded
by reverend sung myung moon back in the
70s and had a very huge following all
around the world they were probably best
known for those mass weddings that they
would have like in madison square garden
he has since passed away and now there
are three splinter groups started by his
wife and the three sons and some of
those groups are quite active especially
the one in america that's run by sean
moon and he wears a crown of bullets as
do some of the other followers reverend
moon was quite friendly with george bush
daddy bush and his wife who used to
attend some of their gatherings at
boomer bats asked i wonder
do cult members join when they are at
the brink of insanity or are they
already mentally ill or are they
perfectly functioning humans that were
casually looking for a new set of
beliefs to follow and later on lost
their sanity in the process
oh at boomer bats i get this question so
often
you know people have the idea that the
people who get into cults
have some kind of mental problems and
that's absolutely not the case first of
all cults want to recruit high
functioning individuals they want people
with money and they want people with
connections they want you to be a good
worker they want you to work very hard
cult leaders don't work very much
they're usually pretty lazy so everyone
else has to keep the show going you know
cults aren't going to take care of you
you're there to take care of them so
they're looking for the kind of person
who can perform for them who can bring
in good contacts that will lend
legitimacy to the group now while you're
in the cult you may develop all kinds of
anxiety and panic attacks because of the
the stress of what you're living under
but it's good idealistic people who get
into cults they think they're going to
change the world or do something
important in life and then they're taken
advantage of at sarah's sky blue asks
what defines a cult pretty sure you
could call anything occults first of all
we have the leader who is charismatic
and usually a narcissist second we have
what i call the transcendent belief
system that gives you the answer to
everything third are what i call systems
of control things like what you should
wear what you should eat who you can
marry how many kids you should have or
shouldn't have and fourth is the systems
of influence the cult will be playing on
fear love grief you know whatever your
emotions are to get you to comply and
conform at leonacas asks how do you
leave a cult
asking for a friend well leo nachos
here's what i think you should tell your
friend it's not easy to leave a cult
it's one of the hardest things someone's
ever going to do and the most important
thing is for those of us on the outside
to be that safe haven let the person
know that you're a place that they can
come to whenever they want they can
sleep if they want to sleep they don't
have to talk so it's just a matter of
having some resources on the outside
that may help you to build a new life
onsider asks what types of cults are
illegal according to u.s law it's not
the cults per se that are illegal it's
what they do
so in order to hold some group
accountable you have to have enough
evidence of some kind of criminal
activity so that law enforcement might
get involved many cults will become a
religion and hope that they can hide
behind the first amendment atlectual
asks i couldn't help but wonder
when does a cult become a religion and
when does a religion become a cult first
of all not every religion becomes a cult
and not every cult becomes a religion
cults can be any type of belief system
it doesn't have anything to do with
religion at all it can be new age it can
be some kind of philosophy a religion
may have guidelines for you to live by
like be a good person be kind to your
neighbor don't use contraception but in
most cases people from that religion
aren't coming into your bedroom at night
to see if you're using contraception so
that's one of the main differences
between a cult and a religion in a
religion you should have freedom and
independent thinking
at hamz007 asks who has experience
escaping from a cult well at hamm's
double 07 many people have escaped from
colts and i'm happy to say that i'm one
of them i was in a political cult it was
left wing and we were planning and
hoping to make the revolution we
actually didn't think it would happen in
our lifetime we saw ourselves as martyrs
for the cause but what happened is after
about ten and a half years everyone was
so burned out some of us in leadership
realized how corrupt the leader was and
just taking advantage of us so we called
together everybody and we told them what
was going on and we had a vote and we
unanimously voted to expel her and to
dissolve the organization and so
everyone got out it was wonderful that's
absolutely not a common scenario i can
think of maybe one perhaps two other
groups that ended in that way at jos x
asks how do cults even happen like
people really be letting themselves be
brainwashed like that so at josecs let
me explain how this works we all have
days when we don't feel so great or
maybe we just moved to a new town or
maybe we just got divorced or maybe our
dog just died and at that point we hear
a person up there who's giving us some
kind of pitch that's going to change
your life now that pitch has to appeal
to you it's not going to appeal to
everybody you know i always say i never
would have joined a meditation group
because i can't sit still that long but
a political group that was going to
change the world well that sounded
fantastic to me right and then you make
that commitment and often that
commitment is made in front of other
people in my group we had to stand up
and make a pledge that we were going to
do this for the rest of our life people
don't get brainwashed overnight this is
a re-socialization process it's changing
you to be the person that they want you
to be to be the good conforming
complying cult member who will go out
and recruit other people and do the work
for the cult aunt niclor asks why do
cults always have everyone wear the same
outfit well at nick lore not every cult
does that the rajneesh cult back in the
day where everyone had to wear orange
some shade of orange here for example is
a group where everyone's dressed the
same the reason they do that is to break
down your sense of self if everyone
looks alike there's no individuality
among you and it's an easy way to get
you to conform and comply to the demands
of the group at cloverducey asked why
were cults so big in the 70s y'all i'll
never get it the 70s of course were a
very special time new age ideas were
taking hold and of course that was a
time when there were many communes and
so people were living together and that
can be a breeding ground for a cult to
take hold if you have someone who wants
power and takes advantage of that
environment the 70s was also a time when
there were a lot of political cults that
was the the end of the vietnam war era
and so people on the left were looking
for something to do and a lot of these
little groups got started you may
remember this one patricia hurst who was
kidnapped by the symbionese liberation
army this is her after her
indoctrination where she
took the name tanya and went along to
rob some banks including the hibernia
bank in san francisco at mobmom asks how
did jim jones even establish jonestown
it seems unreal here we have jim jones
who was a pastor who had a huge
following so jones had a very lively
quite large church in san francisco
where he did faith healing and other
things and and had very loyal followers
one of the local newspapers was going to
write an expose about him and so he had
already been sort of planning for this
and had already bought land in guyana so
he told all his followers to go there
and so everyone went there 900 and some
people and that's where the tragedy
happened he took away their passports so
even if you wanted to leave you couldn't
leave the children were brutally
punished sometimes hung upside down in
wells so people were afraid they were
afraid for their life and they were
there they were in the middle of nowhere
eventually an investigation was called
and the congressman from california came
to investigate jones had them murdered
the poisoned
flavor aid which is commonly called
kool-aid now was made and and people
were forced to take that the children
were injected first and in the end there
was the mass suicide murder that
happened of 913 people died and over 200
children at mandatory asks why does
peloton feel like a cult it may feel
like a cult because you're sweating so
much
but also there's a sense of
accomplishment a sense of belonging
you're with other people who are also
doing peloton and that feels really good
of course it's important to recognize
that the fitness industry has quite a
few groups that are quite cult-like so
it's important to check out what you're
doing and be a good consumer at userbits
asks how did hashtag nexium become a
cult imagine hoping to buy a timeshare
or brush up your personal skills and
getting sucked into sex trafficking well
keith renery was a con artist and he was
skilled at setting up sort of pyramid
schemes nexium started out as as a kind
of multi-level marketing program where
people would take these courses and then
be expected to recruit other people into
these courses some of them were
encouraged to move to albany new york
where the headquarters was and people
set up centers in different cities
around the country keith of course was a
pedophile and a sadist
so he set up kind of a cult within the
cult which was called das where each
woman had a certain number of people
below her they were to recruit other
people into this but the real purpose of
it was to feed women to to reneri for
sex the other part of it was that he
liked really skinny women and sophie's
women were told to be on a 500 calorie a
day diet and they were just becoming
completely emaciated they were no longer
having their menstrual periods their
hair was falling out it was absolutely
brutal fortunately
some people worked very hard to blow the
whistle on this and happily keith renery
is now in prison for 120 years
at matt griffith asks what kind of cults
are people who sell hair products on
instagram a part of i'm not sure what
you're specifically referring to matt
griffith but there are certainly a lot
of cults and cult-like groups within the
wellness industry selling all kinds of
products and potions and things to make
you feel better at jessica evans asks
serious question
how many people does it take to form a
cult
can a cult be just two people yes
jessica evans a cult can be just two
people and i call those one-on-one cults
and we see a great deal of those these
days people are becoming more aware of
practices like gaslighting and what
happens when a person has that kind of
control over you so a cult can be any
size from thousands of members to just
two at uncoveringthetruth asks when do
cult members realize they're in a cult
well this of course is what i always
hope for that someone will realize
they're in a cult and then try to figure
out how to get out i think everyone in a
cult has doubts and those doubts you
know they're not able to express them so
people have these doubts and the way i
see it is they kind of put them on a
shelf in the back of their head right
and that shelf gets heavier and heavier
and hopefully at one point the shelf
gets heavy enough that it's breaks and
at that moment they'll realize that
something's wrong they may not identify
it as a cult but they think that this is
not a group that's in their best
interest and they probably should think
about leaving
true reflections asks is it just me or
were cults more prevalent pre-internet
social media hashtag people magazine
investigates yes there have always been
cults we can go back in history to the
roman empire to the essenes to the days
of jesus it's a social human phenomenon
that's always been with us there
certainly were a lot of cults
pre-internet but of course as we see
today there are many many cults that are
operating on the internet certainly we
saw this with q anon and all the other
kinds of conspiracy theories so yes
there are cults before and there will be
cults again and there are always cults
at old normality asks what do cult
members do when the cult collapses all
that dedication to for absolutely
nothing when the cult collapses it's
often quite tragic for the believers
because now that their whole life has
just fallen apart so they have to figure
out what do i do now people may drift
away
splinter groups may start someone may
try to take over and rise as the leader
and in some circumstances there may have
been a violent ending as as we saw with
the branch davidians in waco but again
that kind of thing is usually the
exception and not every group is going
to end that way at lowain asks do cult
leaders know that their cult leaders
probably 99
are con artists and they know exactly
what they're doing some of them may
eventually become delusional because
they get away with so much for so long
so they kind of get carried away and
actually think that they're god but it's
really a combination of that narcissism
and then perhaps they have a bit of
sociopathy or psychopathy but i think
most of them are sitting back and
laughing at their followers
so those are all the questions for today
and i hope that if you know someone in a
cult you'll have some tools now to be
able to help them get out i hope that if
you're in a cult you'll find a way to
get out and go through the kind of
recovery that's needed to get on with
your life thanks for watching cult
support